CP à travers des animations des
démonstrations et également des essais
le public a pu découvrir les innovations
et avancées technologique de demain
notamment le smart grid développé par
vdcom qui permet de stocker l'énergie
des voitures ce qu'on propose ici c'est
comment on peut stocker l'énergie il y a
deux types de stockage un stockage type
court terme c'estàd par exemple tout
simplement en rechargeant les batteries
d'un véhicule électrique tout comme vous
rechargez les batteries de votre
smartphone tous les jours c'est un moyen
de stocker de l'énergie à côté on sur un
stockage long terme qui est par exemple
fabriquer de l'eau en hydrogène vdcom a
décidé d'utiliser ce système à hydrogène
pour des vélo mais d'autres sont allés
plus loin comme la société hype qui a
décidé de créer des taxis à hydrogène
c'est le Véhicule du Futur c'est le
Véhicule du Futur parce que là sur les
véhicules électriques l'inconvénient
c'est la recharge qui prend des heures
oui ça se chiffre en heure donc pour
pouvoir recharger avoir une recharge
complète donc là une recharge sur ce
type de véhicule se fait sur le côté
donc on a un réservoir d'hydrogène donc
la recharge effectu peu près 5 minutes
on part sur une autonomie de quasiment
500 km véhicule très pro qui rejette que
de la vapeur d'eau sachez qu'une flotte
de taxis à hydrogène est déjà en
circulation dans Paris pour en savoir
plus rendez-vous sur le site
www.hype.fr